Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ayildes und ich bin auch dieser Restitution als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen an einem Musikisch prüfen. Sind Sie Interessant?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Michael Lindemann.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Michael schreibt sich M-I-C-H-A-E-L. Michael.
Und Lindemann, L-I-N-D-E-M-A-N-N. Lindemann.
Okay, Herr Lindemann.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie, Herr Lindemann?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 25. Mai 1959.
Können Sie bitte ja wiederholen?
1959.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,82 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
88 kg.
Okay, was ist hier sonst?
Ja, ich habe seit einigen Stunden, ich sage mal, 8 Stunden vielleicht, sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
Die werden auch immer schlimmer.
Und es geht mir nicht gut.
Ich habe so einen starken Druck im Kopf, im Hinterkopf, aber auch seitlich an den Schläfen.
Mir ist übel.
Ich habe zweimal erbrochen.
Okay, Sie haben seit 8 Stunden Kopfschmerzen im Hinterbereich.
Hauptsächlich, aber einziglich im ganzen Kopf, aber hauptsächlich im Hinterkopf und an der Seite hier.
Und die Schmerzen sind mit der Zeit schlimmer.
Ja.
Können Sie mir beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen aufgetreten sind,
eher langsam oder...
Plötzlich.
Langsam, eher langsam.
Okay.
Wie sind die Schmerzen eher dumpf, brennend oder...
Sie sind mehr so dumpf und bohrend.
Okay.
Und Sie haben auch Üblichkeit und Erbrochen.
Ja.
Wie sagt Ihre Erbrochen aus?
Das war so schleimig, gelblich schleimig.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Vorbei eines sehr leichte und 10 sehr starkes Schmerzen entspricht.
7 bis 8?
8 bis 8.
Okay.
Hatten Sie so etwas für die nischen Schmerzen?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Und hatten Sie etwas Unfall?
Nein.
Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich bin nicht gestürzt oder so.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Haben Sie überlegt?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Erklärung dafür.
Okay.
Und Sie haben Üblichkeit.
Auch ist vor seit acht Jahren, acht Stunden.
Ja, die Üblichkeit war ziemlich schnell.
Ja, die ist ziemlich schnell gekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch eine an der Bischwäde?
Ja, mir ist schwindelig und ich kann auch nicht so gut sehen.
Ich sehe etwas verschwommen.
Das fällt mir auf.
Normalerweise kann ich gut sehen.
Ich habe gute Augen, aber ich sehe jetzt auch ziemlich verschwommen.
Ja.
Okay.
Und können Sie mir beschreiben, wie ist Ihre Schwindelig?
So mehr so im Kreis.
Kreisschwindeln.
Arrussell.
Okay.
Und Sie haben auch Verstörende.
Ja.
Haben Sie Vorerkrankungen oder leiden Sie an kröntischen Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Blutdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe hohen Blutdruck schon seit 20 Jahren.
Und da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Ja, ich nehme auch Medikamente ein.
Hämse.
Welche Medikamente?
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme einmal Bisoprolol.
Okay.
Wie viele Milligramm?
Milligramm, dahinter steht 5.
Und da nehme ich zwei Tabletten pro Tag.
Einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch Kandisatan.
Acht steht dahinter.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine halbe abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch ein Medikament, das heißt HCT.
HCT dahinter steht 25.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Okay.
Und dann nehme ich noch eine Tablette zur Senkung der Harnsäure.
Das heißt Allopurinol.
Da steht 300 hinter, da nehme ich eine halbe Tablette morgens.
Okay.
Wir haben auch Ököönemi.
Erhörte Ön...
Harnsäure, Harnsäure, ja.
Ja, Harnsäure.
Okay.
Ich habe einige Fragen über allgemeine Zustand.
Haben Sie Fieber und Nachschweiß oder Stüttel?
Also Fieber habe ich nicht.
Fieber habe ich nicht.
Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder so genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang habe ich jeden Tag.
Wasserlassen muss ich ein bis zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette.
Aber das auch schon länger.
Aber ich kann danach wieder gut schlafen.
Das stört mich nicht.
Okay.
Diese Beschwerden, haben Sie...
Hat diese Beschwerde neu angefangen oder hatten Sie schon lange?
Die Kopfschmerzen oder was machen?
Nein, nein.
Das Wasserlassen habe ich schon einige Jahre.
5 Jahre, 4, 5 Jahre.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich operiert an den Mandeln.
Da war ich 10 Jahre alt vielleicht.
Dann wurde ich auch noch am Blinddarm operiert.
Das war auch so mit 11 oder 12.
Und dann habe ich einen Bruch gehabt am Unterschenkel auf der linken Seite,
nach Fußball spielen.
Da war ich 28 Jahre alt.
Das war das linke Schienenbein.
Das war gebrochen.
Und da musste ich operiert werden.
Okay.
Ist Komplikation bei der Operation und Komplikation?
Nein.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Brauchen Sie Herr Lindemann?
Ja, ich brauche schon lange 20 Zigaretten so am Tag, eine Schachtel,
45 Jahre ungefähr.
Okay.
Zinken Sie Alkohol?
Abends trinke ich eine Flasche Bier.
Das ist so 0,5.
Okay.
Nennen Sie irgendwelche Drogen?
Nein.
Wie war das mit der Blutdruck?
Ich messe zwischendurch selber, aber nicht so regelmäßig.
Ich habe das letzte Mal vor 10 Tagen gemessen.
Da war der Blutdruck 145 auf gut 90.
Er war meistens immer so darum.
Ich lasse das auch immer.
Ich habe das auch immer.
Er war meistens immer so darum.
Ich lasse das einmal im Jahr gründlich beim Arzt untersuchen.
Der Arzt meinte auch, es wäre etwas zu hoch.
Ich sollte versuchen, immer ein bisschen mehr Gewicht abzunehmen.
Und natürlich auch mit dem Brauchen.
Aber das habe ich bisher nicht geschafft.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben seit acht Jahren nicht gemessen?
Nein, da habe ich nicht gemessen.
Er hat eine Frage über Familien an einem Nähe.
Leben Sie da noch?
Nein, der Vater ist verstorben mit 76 Jahren an einem Schlaganfall.
Okay.
Und die Mutter ist 94 Jahre alt.
Sie lebt noch.
Ja.
Ein Bruder ist 64 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin inzwischen Rentner.
Ich habe aber bis vor einem Jahr als Dachdecker gearbeitet.
Okay.
Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Wir haben zwei Kinder.
36 und 38 Jahre alt.
Die sind gesund.
Ja, Herr Lindemann.
Jetzt habe ich alle wichtige Fragen.
Nein.
Sind Sie ausstellend geimpft, Herr Lindemann?
Ja, in meinem Beruf habe ich ja oft Impfungen gekriegt.
Bei Verletzungen, so Wunschdarkrammen.
Ich habe auch die
Verletzungen gekriegt.
Ich habe auch die Corona-Impfung gekriegt.
Ich habe auch eine Impfung gegen Lungenentzündung gekriegt.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der letzten 6 Monaten in Ausland?
Ich war in Österreich im Sommer.
Ich habe in der letzten 6 Monate in der Stadt.
Ich habe in der Stadt in der Stadt.
Ich habe in der Stadt in Österreich.
Im Spätsommer war ich in Österreich eine Woche.
Aber sonst habe ich meine Ferien eher in Deutschland verbracht.
Okay.
Herr Lindemann.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Jetzt werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde sie körperlich untersuchen.
Wenn alle Ergebnisse sind,
werde ich mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Dann informiere ich alles.
Schild für Schild.
Okay.
Das können wir so machen.
Ich werde sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich habe auch schon 2 Tabletten Paracetamol genommen.
Vor 3 Stunden hat aber nichts geholfen.
Was gibt es noch?
Darfi.
Herr Lindemann.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Nein, das spüre ich nicht.
Aber ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ich bin den Schwindel auch sehr unsicher.
Ich sitze mich lieber hin.
Das ist besser, dass ich sitze.
Es ist kribbelnd und so etwas habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie
in der Wohnung ruhig verhalten, da war auch nicht laut oder so. Das kann ich jetzt schlecht sagen,
aber Lichtempfindlichkeit habe ich eher nicht. Danke. Darf ich? Ja. Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ihre Bluthochdruck gemessen? Ja, wie gesagt vor zwei Wochen mal.
Da hatte ich so 145 auf 90 bis 95. Ich messe nicht so oft. Okay, und haben Sie sehr
Entsteuerungen? Ja, das ist so verschwommen. Ja, ja. Spraustöerungen oder
Hörungsstörungen gibt es auch oder? Nein, nicht Sehsteuerungen. Okay, und jeder
bei Schweden, Hauptsache im Hinterkopf. Ja, also es tut im ganzen Kopf weh, aber ich
habe den Eindruck so hauptsächlich hinten im Kopf und an der Seite, hier an den Schläfen.
Nein, die sind nur im Kopf. Und meine letzte Vorlage, wie lange wird diese
Beschwerden? Ja, jetzt seit acht Stunden. Ungefähr acht Stunden schon.
Immer ständig oder elegent? Die sind ständig. Wir haben jetzt langsam angefangen und sind in
letzter Zeit schlimmer geworden, stärker. Okay, danke. Ja, und Darfi? Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie innerhalb dieser acht Stunden einmal bewusst sein verloren? Nein,
bewusst sein habe ich nicht verloren. Wir suchen Sie Ihrem Haushaltsbibliokalmäßig?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, ich gehe einmal im Jahr so zum Hausarzt zur Untersuchung mit Blut und
der macht dann auch ein EKG und dann kriege ich auch meine Impfungen, Grippeimpfung und Coronaimpfung
und so, aber häufiger gehe ich da nicht hin. Er sagt auch, ich soll mindestens zweimal im Jahr
kommen und häufiger meinen Blutdruck messen zum Beispiel. Ja, was mache ich nicht? Nimmt, messen
Sie Ihr Blutdruck selbst oder? Ja, wir haben zu Hause ein Blutdruckgerät und dann messen
ich meinen Blutdruck und meine Frau mal Ihrem Blutdruck. Aber wie gesagt, das ist nicht so häufig.
Ist Ihre Blutdruck gut angestellt mit Ihren Medikamenten? Ja, wie gesagt vor zwei Wochen habe
ich gemessen, da war er so bei 145 auf 90, 95. Danke. Helden Dämer, Darfi? Ja.
Aber unser Bruchschmerzen? Nein. Hat sich Ihr Urinmenge in letzter Zeit in den letzten
zwei Tagen verändert? Urinmenge, ja. Glaube ich nicht, nicht auffällig. Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Danke. Beachten, Entschuldigung, beachten Sie ich Diäte. Ich meinte, essen Sie wenige Salze
oder nicht? Ja, das hat mir der Hausarzt früher besagt, weil ich doch immer gerne
gesalzen habe, ich soll mal meinen Salz reduzieren. Das habe ich auch gemacht. Das schmeckt mir
nicht so gut, dann das Essen. Also ich achte da nicht so drauf, muss ich sagen. Sie achten
nicht, danke schön. Gut, wenn jetzt keine Fragen sind und der Kollege noch etwas sich
vorbereiten muss, dann sagen wir mal noch zwei Minuten und dann. Einige Kollegen
möchten wissen, ob Sie muskelschwege Schwäche haben. Muskelschwäche? Ja. Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich fange an. Okay. Guten Tag, Herr Obert. Ich habe einen neuen Patenten aufgenommen und ich
möchte dem Fahrer kurz vorstellen. Okay. Es geht um Michael Lindermann, der 66-jährige Patent.
Er kam zu uns wegen seit acht Stunden bestehender, beurrediente, langsam aufgetretenen
und die Schmerzen seien dunf und bohrend. Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 und 8.
Und als Begleitzemptome nauser vomitus und Sästörungen.
Sästörungen, der Patient hat gesagt, glaube ich, verschwommendes Sehen, würde ich
vielleicht allgemein dann sagen, Visusstörung. Visus, ja. Visus, V-I-S-U-S,
Visusstörung oder Visusminderung. Ja, okay. Er habe zwei Mal Erbruschen. Das vomitus war
schleimlich und gerblich. Als vegetative Anemnese gab er an Nocturne ein, zwei Mal
pro Nacht. Nocturia, ja. Ja, Nocturia. Als vor Erkrankungen gab er Artiliohypertonie seit
zwei Jahren. 20 Jahren. Und Hyperurenemi. Hyperurekemi, also Harnsäureerhöhung, ja. Okay.
Hyperurekemi und dagegen nehme er Bisoprolol, 5 mg, Morgen und Abend 1 Tablette, Kandesatan, 8 mg,
Morgen 1, Abends halbe Tablette, H-C-T, 25 mg, Abends 1 Tablette. H-C-T, ja, H-C-T. Wissen Sie, was das heißt?
Die Abkürzung H-C-T? Nein, ja. Das ist die Abkürzung für Hydrochlorotiazid. Hydrochlorotiazid ist ein
Dioretikum, ja. Wirkt über die Niere. Hydrochlorotiazid, H-C-T, ja. Okay. Und alle Prüner, es war 200 mg,
morgens halbe Tablette, 1 mg. Okay. Und er habe keine Allergen und Unverträglichkeit und er sei
vorstellend geimpft gegen auch Thetanus, Covid und Influenza. Und er rufe seit 25 Jahren, 20
Jahre, das entspricht 45 Präkitiars. Okay. Und sie denken ein vielleicht vielleicht Bier am Abend, pro Abend. Und ja,
als Familien eine Mese gab, dass seine Vater im Alter von 76 Jahren ja an Apoplex verstoben sei. Und seine
Mutter, seine Mutter, die 94 Jahre, die hat es mellutus Typ 2. Okay. Und seine Bruder der 64 Jahre,
leide an Atelier-Hiphthoni und er sei jetzt Redner, er war da Brecker für her und er sei verheiratet und
habe zwei gesunde Kinder, Erwachsene Kinder. Okay. Ja. Ist irgendetwas bekannt, ist der Patient
gestürzt oder hat er ein Infekt gehabt oder irgendwas Fieber? Nein, Fieber, Schüttefrost oder
Unfall, Erwutung verneint. Okay. Und der Patentin wurde verneint und gegen Schmerzen,
nicht ein HBR, zweitablet Parasitomor, aber er hat keine Verbesserung bekommen. Okay. Ja. Und er habe
nicht Blutdruck gemessen. Ja. Er hat, glaube ich, gesagt zuletzt vor zwei Wochen, hat er Blutdruck
gemessen. Ja. Ja. Okay. Hat der Patient solche Beschwerden schon einmal gehabt? Nein, er habe
vorher nicht habe Beschwerden nicht gehabt. Okay. Gut. Was ist Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose? Und meine
Verdachtstdiagnose, supertancielle Krise. Okay. Und als die Pferenziatdiagnose dich kommen,
subarachnoidal Blutung oder Diabletzmeilutusentgliedung oder hyperhypergulchemi. Okay. Also,
Sie haben einmal gesagt, differentialdiagnostisch subarachnoidal Blutung. Ja. Okay. Ja. Kann die
Hälftigkeit der Kopfschmerzen erklären? Ja. Kann es auch ein Glaukomensein? Ein Glaukom-Anfall?
Ja, das kann sein. Ja. Denken Sie, das verschwommene Sehen, das verschwommene Sehen vielleicht,
zumindest, okay. Gut. Hypertensive Krise als Verdachtstdiagnose bin ich vollkommen mit einverstanden. Bei
der Vorgeschichte des Patienten natürlich auch. Danke erst mal. Ich konnte Sie gut verstehen. Sie
haben das systematisch auch gut gemacht. Haben die meisten Fachbegriffe auch gut gebracht.
Wichtig, was ich mir gewünscht hätte, ist, dass Sie bei dieser Beschwerdesymptomatik als allererstes
Vitalwerte messen bei den Patienten. Denn ein Patient mit so starken Kopfschmerzen in
ihrer Ambulanz kommt, würde ich als erstes den Blutdruck messen. Ja, als erstes. Und dann
vielleicht schauen, wie der Blutdruck ist. Es kann sein, dass der sehr hoch ist, der
Blutdruck, dass Sie dann gleich versuchen, zumindest moderat langsam den Blutdruck zu senken,
auch schon in der Ambulanz, wenn der Patient einen Blutdruck von 250 hat oder so. Lassen Sie
Ihr Kind ruhig zuschauen. Hat die Tasse dran. Also, da würde ich versuchen, Vitalwerte zu messen,
Blutdruck auf alle Fälle, vielleicht SBO2 und vielleicht auch ein EKG machen. Aber
dem Blutdruck würde ich zuallererst messen. Weil das könnte in der Prüfung auch gewünscht sein,
dass Sie das tun bei solchen Zuständen, die ganz starken Kopfschmerzen. Und die Kopfschmerzen mit
7 bis 8 sind ja schon als, finde ich schon außergewöhnlich stark zu werden. Paracetamol hat
gar nicht geholfen. Da muss man schon mal dran denken. Okay, aber ansonsten würde ich sagen,
das sollten Sie einfach tun. Sagen Sie, ich unterbreche jetzt hier gerade die Befragung,
Herr Lindemann, und möchte zunächst erst mal Ihren Blutdruck messen und Ihren Sauerstoff
gehalten Blut. Und dann habe ich schon mal einen besseren Überblick. Das wäre, glaube ich,
ganz gut. Gut, aber ansonsten, finde ich, haben Sie das gut gemacht. Wie gesagt,
mein Einstellung ist bei solchen Sachen lieber einmal mehr die Vitalwerte gleich zu Anfang messen,
wie starker Kopfschmerz, Brustschmerz, Bauchschmerz, also Abdominalschmerz,
Turakalerschmerz. Würde ich erst immer schnell mal sagen, ich messe jetzt Ihren Blutdruck,
ich messe Ihren Sauerstoffgehalt und ich messe vielleicht ein einfaches EKG,
nehme ich ab, ein Monitor-EkG. Das ist schnell gemacht und das beruhigt Sie und die Prüfung
Kommission, die sind dann sehr zufrieden, dass Sie das tun. Gut, ja, aber ansonsten finde ich,
ist das wichtig. Bei Kopfschmerzen würde ich eben immer auch mal daran denken, dass es
eventuell vom Augen-Innen-Druck kommt, dass es eventuell nicht doch ein Glaukom-Anfall ist.
Das weiß man nicht genau, aber zumindest, dass Sie das im Kopf behalten, dass das mit
eine Rolle spielt. Hatte der Patient Lichtempflichtkeit? Nein, das ist gefragt worden.
Lichtempfindigkeit, glaube ich, und Lärmemfindlichkeit, das wurde gefragt. Das hat der Patient in diesem Fall
jetzt verneint. Ich glaube, Abbesenheit von Lichtempflichtkeit, Spreckgängeln, Glaukoma.
Ja, natürlich, aber ich würde es trotzdem so ein bisschen in meine Überlegung mit einbeziehen,
weil Patienten ja oft, die sind so stark vom Schmerz beeinträchtigt wie dieser Patient,
vielleicht, dem Feld vielleicht auch nicht alles ein. Ich würde trotzdem zumindest mal daran denken,
dass man den Augen-Indruck doch bei Gelegenheit auch bei dem Patienten kontrolliert.
Glaukoma, vor allem nicht alle Protokoll. Deswegen möchte ich fragen, die echte Diagnose
der Patienten. Ja, also wie gesagt, es gibt immer wieder, glaube ich, das kann ich mich auch
erinnern, Glaukom-Anfälle. Es ist ja lange, man denkt da nicht oft dran, manchmal, wenn es
einseitig ist und sagt, ja, ich habe hier auch Druck auf dem Auge und das Auge ist vielleicht vom
palpatorischen Her viel härter. Gibt es ja solche mitunter Hinweise, aber der Patient ist ja auch
noch nicht untersucht worden. Das sind ja bisher nur Schilderungen. Und wir wissen nicht, ist das
Auge vielleicht etwas gerötet als das andere Auge oder so. Zumindest daran denken, sage ich jetzt mal.
Vorrangig ist sicherlich der Verdacht auf eine hypertone Krise bei den Patienten und eventuell
natürlich eine Suparithnoritalblutung, die ja auch so sehr heftige Stakelschmerzen machen kann,
die oft für meinen Begriff vielleicht ein bisschen schneller pro Kredient sind. Der Patient sagt,
das hat so langsam angefangen. Aber ja, an erster Stelle würde ich an die hypertone Krise denken.
Das werden sie dann ja relativ schnell auch feststellen, schon in der Ambulanz, ob vielleicht
der Blutdruck einfach viel zu hoch ist bei den Patienten. Gut, ja vielen Dank erst mal und ich
wünsche Ihnen weiter gute Vorbereitung für Ihre Prüfung und dass das gut läuft.